ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Whitney Houston
it was my goal to to hold on to her
integrity and to make sure that we dealt
with her life as sensitively as possible
and from a place of real and love for
her that was really scary but I look
back on it now and I'm glad I took that
on
[Music]
[Applause]
for me it was about vocal tone you know
naturally you age but also there is like
a raspiness to her voice that I wanted
to to try and Achieve so we got an
understanding that she's aging but also
there may be some vocal damage that's
happening and because of how much she's
working but also because of her
lifestyle my dream
sing what I want to sing be how I want
to be it was a challenge but it was
something that was really fascinating to
me and something I wanted to achieve
technically to allow the audience to
suspend their disbelief I might have
just heard the greatest voice of Her
generation for Stanley Tucci who plays
legendary music producer Clive Davis he
needed to get
it maybe maybe it's got to have a hook a
hook yeah
I'll give it a hook he's gonna see every
frame of it so you want to make sure
that you you get it right luckily I met
him and I could use use that meanwhile
everyone has their favorite Whitney song
hated
The Greatest Love of All I'm Every Woman
is is one of my favorites
I want to dance with somebody there's
just so many